it's almost a metaphor for falling in
love you date a lot of people and you
flirt with a lot of people and
everything's going great but then you
meet the right one and you once you once
I realize that oh okay this has grabbing
this is genuinely legit and now I'm
maybe I'm thinking about music choices
for it and web spinning about it maybe
it gets me to actually start writing a
little bit pretty shortly into that
process I'll probably end up writing
something that's like okay I'm doing
this now first you read a script and or
a book or you get ideas and You Begin to
Fall in Love You don't know what you're
going to follow the most important thing
is what you fall in love with and the
reason you fall in love is an
abstraction nobody knows why they fall
in love with this woman and not this one
and I realize that my own thought
processes are very hard to Define in
terms of What story do you want to make
into a film you know it does become this
uh very uh you know why do you find one
particular girl attractive or why did
you marry your wife